boys boys
well i just imagine john winchester all
the time as negan
which is jeffrey dean morgan boys season
three looks like we got a first look
teaser here
we don't know much about the soldier boy
characters being up front about that but
we do
love the boys tv series if you haven't
seen our season two reactions they're up
here on the channel right now and we
were gonna film the supernatural season
seven finale reaction today for our
patreon but
you know we gotta see what jensen echols
has moved on to with eric kripke we're
gonna watch emergency awesome's
breakdown
and uh see what thoughts spring up from
it
[Music]
hello america as the original superhero
i assure you that you are in safe hands
with us
i'm soldier boy and i approve this
message
god bless you soldier boy
now look there's been a little drama
but i want to reassure you here and now
superheroes
are still the good guys
he's got kind of an almighty american
voice over dub
hello people he's got the traditional
such a
fading heroic american hero
type of voice voice of heroes i am the
voice of heroism yeah
oh man and you just having homelanders
come in there
and just the idea it just hit me in this
moment jensen ackles
and anthony anthony star anthony starr
and anthony stark interacting with each
other
oh that's gonna be such good scene work
you can
feel it you just know it's gonna be good
scene work all right let's go into this
a little more they just dropped jensen
ackles first look as soldier boy and
i'll explain what's going on with his
character he's obviously going to be
like the new
really big character they're introducing
like stormfront was the brand new
character during season two
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
the show runner has already revealed
some of what's going on with the
episodes right now like he's been
posting a lot of his own reactions in
the edit bay because they've been
filming for a while now in general
i've heard about the hirogasm like you
can see him trying to get ripped
like slowly working out obviously
full-blown costume here you can see
they're going for a very captain america
vibe because
soldier boy is basically the boy's
version of marvel's captain america or
the avengers captain america however you
want to think about him
even though usually when you think of
the boys you think mostly of dc comics
because the seven
is sort of their version of the justice
league but the boyz is satire and parody
of a lot of marvel characters as well
with a lot of their other teams
particularly the payback team which is a
big reference to marvel's avengers like
the revengers
so i will explain some of the changes
that they're making to soldier boy in
the payback team
during the voice season 3 from the
comics because it will be a slightly
different version oh man okay yeah
so i'm loving this so far yes that's
part of the f especially like boys
season two seem to really lean in
heavily they doubled down on making fun
of dc oh yeah
i've been itching for them to go after
marvel a little bit too oh yeah i mean
there's
so much of a spectrum for them to do and
think of like all the yeah like horrific
ways they could make you cringe when
it's clear
they are beckoning and harkening towards
marvel characters you know
it's gonna be interesting of how we just
had falcon and winter soldier which gave
us
this like john walker character a person
trying to be
captain america yeah and then you're
getting this version of jensen ackles
doing soldier boy which is the riffin on
captain america so two deconstructions
of the cap
and two tv shows let's do this
if you have no idea what's going on
jensen ackles just finished supernatural
they just ended that show and his first
big role after that
is the boys season three because the
showrunner of the boys tv series eric
kripke was also one of the creators on
supernatural so they've already been
a bunch of supernatural actors that have
shown up on the boys before
like bobby singer was a big character
and i think his character's name was
also
the same as his character's name on
supernatural and they've been talking
about bringing jeffrey dean morgan
on the tv show as a new character during
a future season as well i don't know if
jeffrey
morgan is gonna make it into season
three but maybe season four
so obviously the intro there is jensen
ackles doing his
best impression of captain america
soldier boy like he's portrayed by
bot is this very goody two-shoes captain
america type character
big boy scout but in the comics soldier
boy is actually two different characters
so
originally there was a soldier boy that
had the traditional captain america
origin story from the marvel universe
so in the world of the boys back during
world war ii superheroes
vought compound bee that all came out of
world war ii in vogelbaum who started as
a nazi scientist but then came to
america during operation paperclip
and started vaude american where they
started experimenting on americans
creating superheroes the way that you
see them in modern day
but during world war ii the americans
also tried to develop their own super
soldiers serum their own version of
compound v
and that was soldier boy he was their
prototype
superheroes he had no idea how to use
the superpowers he was a terrible
superhero
he got his whole squad killed the
mallory character in the comics
also wound up killing him as revenge for
getting his squad killed
so the original version of boy in the
comics dies back during world war ii
then in present day there's a really
awkward bumbling version of soldier boy
who's this big suck-up wants to be on
the seven
does whatever homelander tells him to do
they have this really
really messed up relationship that the
schoner already said they're not gonna
be doing on the tv show so like they're
doing the herogasm
you're not gonna see that quote-unquote
special scene between the modern soldier
boy and homeland like no we're not going
to do that
homelander did some messed up sex stuff
during season two
it gets even crazier during the herogasm
it's like the worst nightmare version of
spring break with superheroes
but the modern day version of the
character also winds up leading the
payback team which winds up being vots
sort of b
team to the seven the seven is still
like their biggest team their biggest
money earner for all this merchandise
this big financial empire that they're
trying to use these superheroes to
create
remember the whole twist behind creating
superheroes is really just to create
these financial empires
so payback their version of marvel's
avengers is like the b
team to the seven then you put jared
paddle lucky
on the b team yes exactly then you bring
in uh who else can we get let's jarop
had a lucky's white amisha college yeah
we'll get mark shepard and just get
everyone scared everyone from
supernatural and throw them into the
show let's face it jensen knackles
has made the wiser career decision
post-supernatural
than than his brother on that show dang
you know like i
i i figured they wouldn't be able to get
away with doing the herogasm scene but i
wanted them to try a little
bit of it even on doom patrol they had
in season two
you gotta be so careful with your words
so if i just say it really faster you
want to detect rorge that words i'm
trying to say yeah
i think i did i caught it it's the boys
i feel like you get away with
pushing the envelope a lot there i think
i'm gonna read the comic now just to
read that one just to read the hero cast
i mean i would be curious because
they're doing it but i guess they're not
gonna do it at least a hundred percent
verbatim to the stories that is
something i'd be very curious to know
what gets cut and
why yeah yeah but i am bumped we won't
get to see uh jensen apples just
straight up simp for a homelander
and i hope that with uh if they do
introduce this b team that charlie's
talking about which by the way you're
doing a great job of really
communicating
because i'm like oh this is all cool if
there is that b
team i hope that it still keeps soldier
boy the focus
of it and you don't get too bogged down
because you're still dealing with the
seven you're dealing with the boys
they're sort of like the feeder team
like if someone dies on the seven
usually someone from payback gets bumped
up
but here's what they're doing on the tv
show with jensen ackle's character
what they're doing is they're sort of
combining both the old version and the
present day version of soldier boy and
it's just gonna be one character he'll
start out as the original version
created during world war ii
in just like captain america in the
marvel avengers movies
he's going to survive the present day
just like stormfront on the tv show was
created during world war
ii and then just continued to live like
she didn't know it was too living on
until present day
changing her identity but because the
secret of superheroes had been kept
up to the events of season two like the
public didn't learn about compound v
till season two most people believe that
the original soldier boy
died sometime after world war ii like he
grew old and died so they'll have some
backstory for how the new version of
soldier boy shows up
but it's still the same version it'll be
another lie that vap perpetrates the
same way that they sort of
upheld stormfront's lie when giancarlo
esposito's character knew exactly what
was going on with her the whole time
they said the reason why they're
introducing the soldier boy character
now why he's so important for season
three's storyline is because they want
to get into the origin of superheroes
and they're going to use him to tell
that because he's very literally
america's original superhero
even though stormfront is technically
the first superhero because she was the
test subject or the first test subject
that survived the treatment
just talking about the costume changes
too obviously they changed it quite a
bit
from the comic book version of soldier
boy to make it seem even different
from marvel's version of captain america
because he does look a lot more like
captain america's colors in the comics
both versions of the character the one
from world war ii and the one in present
day
the shield does look a little bit more
comic book accurate but i think the
reason why they made this green was so
that marvel
doesn't have any cause to try and sue
them like yes
[Laughter]
it looks a bit more like a soldier it
looks more like captain america from
specifically avengers infinity war and
even with the shield the wakanda shield
that he's equipped with during the
battle that's more what his aesthetic
looks like
yeah green suit material yeah and
everything
and stuff yeah it just has more of like
a military camo color
scheme yeah exactly here's the thing man
it doesn't look like a freaking joke no
he looks like he could kick
i hope he actually gets to be a bit of a
badass and is it just you know a
punchline or something
the way the producers in the cast talk
about his relationship with homelander
makes it sound like it's going to be
kind of antagonistic because homelander
is obviously very territorial
and very insecure like he's just thirsty
for everyone's love and attention
and he's gone even more off the rails
than he already was as of the end of
season two like just jerking off
on top of the empire state building i
believe it was maybe it was the chrysler
building i wasn't quite sure which
building that was
either way he's just doing whatever the
hell he feels like that's this whole
thing i can do whatever i want as he
just slowly goes mad
so a lot of people when they heard the
jensen knackles was going to be this big
force during season three they're like
what's gonna stop homelander from just
punching his fist through his face
on the spot like how does a captain
america level person
fight a homelander level person because
homelander is still meant to be the most
powerful person on the planet
and in the comics their version of
soldier boy is about as strong as
marvel's version of captain america like
chris evans captain america
who obviously could not stand toe-to-toe
with thor like he could probably stand
his ground for like five seconds but
that thor would just throw him like a
rag doll across the battlefield
like when captain america was trying to
stop thanos during infinity war
like just for a brief second he was able
to give him pause but thanos was so
powerful he was just surprised that was
really what stopped him it wasn't the
captain america was strong enough to
stop him
so the showrunner said their big trick
with dealing with this
power scaling problem they have with
homelander because homeland is so
powerful he could kill anybody that he
wanted to on the spot
the way they said they treat him from a
story perspective is that they deal with
him in a more psychological way like
characters attack him
in a more psychological way like he
really doesn't have a kryptonite the way
that superman has a kryptonite
unless you want to think of milk as his
kryptonite so the way they talk about
jessica's version of soldier boy on the
tv show it sounds like he's just going
to be waging a psychological war
against homelander but i'm sure that
they will actually come to some kind of
blows like there'll be some threat of
them actually going
oh i want justin to be a serious regular
during world war ii but you can see how
them keeping him alive this whole time
since world war ii
obviously with the compound v explainer
because it stops you from aging
that's the whole twist with stormfront
at the end of season two the showrunner
said the storm front is coming back so
everyone posts all your darth vader
jokes like she's basically this
burnt piece of toast but she is still
very much alive
this is the way they talked about it in
the writer's room is they couldn't
imagine a worse punishment for her
someone who grew up with the ideals that
she had looking like this hideous
monster
but she will not die unless vaught
allows her to die
and apparently they are definitely not
going to let that happen anytime soon
like even though they have the teaser at
the end of season two where they have a
big press conference where they blame
everything on stormfront she's being
held in a facility and she will answer
for her crimes
aya cash is like i hope they bring me
back but the showrunner did say oh no
she's coming back like she is not dead
she's still very much alive she's just
kind of like a vegetable right now
so i cannot wait to see what they do
with her during season three
is gonna be messed up she should join
the boys team that's right
we'll cheer her around with an oxygen
tank it took me this
long to realize the error of my ways
can i have a job it would be so funny
yeah
newest because you shouldn't keep her in
the show anymore
what purpose is she serving this is just
sad there's a whole episode dedicated to
her just trying to get to the bathroom
shining a light on real experiences the
worst way possible but not quite as
messed up as the herogasm
and it won't be exactly like the comic
book herogasm like they probably won't
go full monty with it but it will be
crazy there's obviously so much other
stuff that's happening here
all the stuff that's happening with
victoria newman and her new agency
this task with regulating superheroes
is secretly a superhero huey thinking
that he left the boys
because he wanted to get away from that
is actually just rushing right into the
belly of the beast
and the whole idea that vaught is the
only source of compound v
and she's a superhero that means that at
some point she would have had to have
gotten it from vaught or been associated
with bot
so i do like the theory that she is
connected to stan edgar and it's all
about his grand plan for getting bought
inside the white house victoria newman
on the show is actually based on a comic
book character called vic
the veep because he was the vice
president but he was also a former
ceo of vaude before stan edgar was so
the tv show is going to be a little bit
different but because of the easter eggs
they're playing with it just sounds like
they're heading to that white house plot
by the end of the series but i don't
know if they're gonna get there by
season four season five
however long the show winds up running
there's a whole bunch of big stuff
happening this week
my full loki episode one video is gonna
post on wednesday
make sure you have alerts enabled so you
don't miss any of that there'll be a
couple big trailers there's lots of
rumors about a spider-man far from home
trailer sometime soon
whatever why don't you mean no way home
yeah i'm rushing charlie
now someone's reposting that far from
home trailer as we speak
my brand new non-spoilery loki episode
one review
and click here for that brand new thor 4
love and thunder first look teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight
i have one little concern about the
shows that i am a little concerned that
they keep
building up so much because neither one
of the seasons has ended in a way yet
where like
where there's a lot that is not wrapped
up right and you still have
so many characters still alive still
existing you've got plot lines that you
start talking about here that i kind of
forgot about
like the very ending one like oh yeah
that's right yeah got so caught up in
soulja boy and all these other things
then
and then uh you know just everything
with homelander and the boys
all that jazz i'm a little concerned
that weirdly i'm thinking about its
final season
of will they be able to wrap everything
up properly
every season presents itself you got the
whole thing with john carlo esposito
being here you know
there's a bunch of story lines already
happening and they're only introducing
more now
let's see either way i'm excited the
show is the show is incredible we got a
lot of great superhero tv
right now and the marvel shows the
deconstruction shows like boys
invincible doom patrol brother academy
like there's so many good shows out
there right now
i miss never sitcoms remember when it
wasn't all just like oh that's so gory
and
messed up in a real world kind of way
oh well guys subscribe to emergency
awesome if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
and last but not least
lance door i wanted to shout you out
because let's face it now that you're
getting married
you can't forget to spend time with the
boys
that's right man you're gonna have your
friends be like dude you
changed ever since you got married
you're gonna be at the firefighting
station they're gonna be like hey
you want to have some routine
barbecue yeah and then you're not gonna
be able to enjoy it because you'd be
like no
my wife is harassing me but the boys
is where you [ __ ] about your wife
that's what friends are for lance if you
want to maintain your marriage
you need your boys to complain to just
or or just come to the season three
reactions and [ __ ] in the comments
and we'll be your boys or go to the fire
station i mean that's a lot more media
you real friends who like you hang out
with on a regular basis who you know
about the struggles that he goes through
stupid that's a bad i'm sorry see that's
why i'm not one of your boys